[Music]
kiernan is with us in
san antonio hi karen how are you hi i'm
doing great how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up hey i'm
28 years old i make about 63 grand a
year i got a
bachelor's in economics a master's in
public administration
got about 130 in student loan debt
i got about 50 sitting in an investment
account
six dashed away and in a
traditional ira in iraq the roth has got
a
grand in it the traditional got five in
it
my employer puts 10 of my salary
in a 401k for me i
job is in dc live in texas
uh because of the covid thing at some
point i'm going to have to go back to
d.c was in the peace corps for three
years
i'm 30
payments into the student loan
forgiveness
portion of the 120 that i've got to make
to to get the balance forgiven at the
end of
that uh cheaper for me to
buy something in dc a condo looks like
because that would be about what i could
afford
what's your question
how do i untangle all of this
it's easy pay off the debt yeah we need
to get rid of student loan debt here's
the thing
to date the 120 month due to serving a
non-profit
student loan forgiveness program
uh the pslf the public service
loan forgiveness program has had
250 000 people apply
after they finish their 120 payments
they have granted 3 700
out of 250 000 it's a scam
wow it's not something you want to bank
on
uh the government has lied and uh
they're not
following through on it there are some
types of student loan forgiveness that
actually do work
that one does not work uh the data on it
is horrendous and heartbreaking because
people spent 10
freaking years working towards it and uh
so you currently work for the peace
corps
no no no no i i work for a an
agency of the federal government
okay so that's why you only make 60 000
when you have a master's degree
in public policy
because you should be making double that
right
um i i suppose having spent three years
in africa and
sometimes not uh not looking for
uh for anything stateside yeah i don't
know
honestly i mean you're you had a a
degree in economics right and a master's
in
public what was it administration
public administration administration
yeah
um and i mean generally that does line
you up for a governmental position
without a doubt but um yeah i i
i think you probably are worth more than
you're paid in the marketplace
um i was a little shocked when i heard
that the masters and i heard that 60k
so anyway the way i untangle it is i
work on the career side of this equation
say am i really being paid what
i am worth in this marketplace and make
sure that you're worth that i could be
wrong
uh i'm not 100 sure and then i'm going
to get about the business of getting the
student loan cleaned up
so that i can begin investing so right
back to anthony's point
clearing the debt is the simple uh
and the correct mathematical way to get
you the closest
way to some kind of uh financial peace
some kind of financial stability some
level of wealth
uh the shortest distance between there
you and there is to clean
clear this student loan debt and you
know here's a problem that i have with
this program dave and
correct me if i'm wrong but it's like a
lot of these people see this well i'm
gonna make the minimum payment when they
have the means to make
a lot more when they have the means to
pay it off some of them do
but they say you know what just make the
minimum living this for ten years
and see if they forgive me then they get
to the end they won't forgive me now
they gotta go another two
three years to pay it off yeah it's
clear yeah and it's
yeah aside from the fact that it's just
misleading exactly
hundreds of thousands of people that
have not been able to
get the government to do what they
thought they were promised
and uh some cases they haven't followed
through on the details in some cases
uh something else is going on but it's
the
it's the ugliest one of the ugliest
stories in the whole student loan
debacle
so um i mean well yeah i i'm not going
to wait on
someone else to fix this if i'm in your
shoes i'm going to work on the income
side of my equation
and i'm going to clear the student loan
debt so that i can get about the
business of building wealth
and i would stop adding to investments
until you get this mess cleaned up
but i really do think you can double
your income i might be wrong i'm wrong a
lot of times but i
he can get it thank you you've got i
think you've got some legitimate
education that's usable in the
marketplace there
yes sir i really do